das Klima steht auf der Kippe der
Klimaschutz duldet keinen Aufschub die
Frage ist nur ob dieser Klimaschutz
erzwungen werden kann und darf oder im
breiten politischen Konsens verwirklicht
werden muss letzteres dauert Jahre die
wir nicht haben wie die Aktivistinnen
und Aktivisten der letzten Generation
behaupten aber legitimiert dies mit der
Brechstange zum Ziel zu gelangen mit
unvermeidlichen Rechtsbrüchen die
Schauplätze dieses Kampfes hat die
letzte Generation mit Bedacht gewählt
Straßen blockieren Kunstwerke
beschädigen wie weit darf klimaprotest
gehen jetzt in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
hier im Studio Theo Schnabel ist hier
organisiert für die Aktionsgruppe letzte
Generation den klimaprotest sie haben
auch einen sogenannten bürgerlichen
Beruf sie sind
wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter an der
naturwissenschaftlichen Fakultät der
Universität Greifswald Sonja eichwede
von der SPD sie sind rechtspolitische
Sprecherin ihrer Bundestagsfraktion und
waren bis zur erlang des Mandats im
Bundestag Richterin im Land Brandenburg
und sind aufgrund ihrer
Abgeordnetentätigkeit im Moment
beurlaubt
Alexander droben von der
cdu/csu-fraktion im Bundestag der
innenpolitische Sprecher von Beruf
Rechtsanwalt und Frau Professorin
Sabrina sayak
protestforscherin an der Universität
Bochum und Abteilungsleiterin für
Konsens und Konflikt im deutschen
Zentrum für integrations- und
Migrationsforschung Herr Schneider wo
sind denn die Grenzen des klimaprotestes
da fragen wir ja heute auch danach die
sie sich als Organisation selbst setzen
ist das jenseits dieser Grenze wo man
sagt Gewalt gegen Sachen und vor allem
Gewalt gegen Personen kommt nicht in
Frage
sie haben das ganz gut getroffen ja die
die Grenze ist immer da wo Gewalt
anfängt oder wo die Gewaltfreiheit
aufhört wir kommen bevor wir unser
Aktion starten zusammen besprechen was
ist eigentlich Gewaltfreiheit nicht nur
im körperlichen Sinne sondern auch in
der Art und Weise wie wir miteinander
sprechen die wir zum Beispiel auch mit
der Polizei sprechen
und genau da der hört es dann auch auf
jadroben haben Sie denn Verständnis für
diesen Protest der letzten Generation
also ich habe Verständnis für
klimaproteste dafür dass man sich für
mehr Klimaschutz auch schnelleren
Klimaschutz einsetzt aber bitte im
Rahmen der geltenden Gesetze man darf
sich selbst nicht über seine Ziele über
die gelben Gesetze stellen das macht
aber die letzte Generation
für euch wieder hat die Unionsfraktion
hat ja einen Leitantrag eingebracht
jetzt Gesetze zu verschärfen gegen die
rechtsprüche die die letzte Generation
vor allen Dingen begeht Nötigung
Sachbeschädigung aus Friedensbruch
gefährlicher Eingriff in den
Straßenverkehr ist das notwendig diese
Gesetze also vor allem das Strafmaß zu
verschärfen ich denke das ist nicht
notwendig zunächst
möchten klimaproteste sind gut sind
notwendig haben auch einen politisches
gesellschaftliches Umdenken in den
letzten Jahren durch Fridays for future
durch viele positive friedliche Proteste
bei uns im Land gebracht aber die Grenze
ist da wo das Strafrecht anfängt wo das
wo die Gesetze gebrochen werden und da
gibt es ganz ganz klar definierte
Grenzen in einer Demokratie die sind
hier überschritten aber die Gesetze die
wir haben sind effektiv sind anwendbar
und ich habe volles Vertrauen in unsere
Justiz und in unsere Gerichte dass da
eben auch entsprechend ermittelt wird
und dann die Strafen folgen müssen sie
auch haben sind sie wollen ja Richterin
gewesen machen das vielleicht auch nach
ihrer Abgeordneten Tätigkeit wieder was
war ja was ist denn das Besondere an dem
Protest an dieser Protestbewegung die
sich letzte Generation nennt
naja ziviler ungeheuer sein ist er geht
ja genau darum mit dem Konflikt zwischen
Legitimität und Legalität zu spielen und
Rechtsbruch oder rechts Graubereich in
Kauf zu nehmen und eben auf
Ungerechtigkeiten und vor allem
Gerechtigkeitsvorstellungen oder dem
Bruch der Normen und Werte die in
Gesetze gegossen sind darauf das
deutlich zu machen
es gibt jetzt ein Ereignis das ihnen
nicht so gut bekommen zu sein scheinen
also ihr Organisation bisher haben sie
ja immer AutofahrerInnen Autofahrer
ausgeregt über Staus die sie verursacht
haben jetzt hat sich ja in der letzten
Woche einen Vorfall in Berlin zugetragen
dass in einem Stau den zwei Aktivisten
von ihnen mit verursacht haben ein
Rüstwagen der Feuerwehr auch in einem
Einsatz befand der kam nicht rechtzeitig
zu einem Einsatz eine Radfahrerin ist
von einem Betonmischer überrollt worden
erst dieses Jahr das hätte überhaupt
keine Relevanz gehabt die Notärztin
sagte jetzt wissen wir dass die
Feuerwehr sagt das hätte sehr wohl eine
gehabt der Betonmischer der
Entschuldigung der Rüstwagen der
Feuerwehr wäre ohne diesen Stau von
ihnen verursacht eine Minute nach der
Notärztin gekommen man hätte diesen
Betonmischer dann umheben können so
musste diese 26 Tonnen diese
Betonmischer ein zweites Mal über das
Bein der Frau fahren um sie zu begleiten
die Frau ist kurz danach verstorben
fühlen sich denn für den Tod dieser
Radfahrerin mitverantwortlich macht es
die betroffen und denken Sie auch über
ihre Protestformen nach die sie jetzt
haben denn das kann ja bei jedem Staub
passieren es gibt auch entsprechende
Informationen des Senats wie oft schon
da Rettungswagen betroffen waren von den
Staus die sie verursacht haben ja also
zunächst ja ich bin absolut betroffen
ich war selber viel Fahrrad jeden Tag
auch leidenschaftlich gern
und diese Bilder die zu sehen diese
Riesenmaschine die da steht und daneben
dieses verbeulte Fahrrad da bekomme ich
das schon mit der Angst zu tun ich habe
einen Neffen eine Nichte sechs und vier
Jahre alt die auch schon unterwegs sind
mit dem Fahrrad
und klar und da kommen da kommt die die
einzelne Betroffenheit die kommen
natürlich als erstes durch
wie sie schon gesagt haben die
die die Berichterstattung hat sich jetzt
wieder geändert am Anfang wurde uns das
Jahr sehr schnell zur Last gelegt und
auch auf einer Faktenlage die danach
völlig unklar war sehr schnell zu Last
gelegt
dann hatte sich eben dann wurde eben
darauf hingewiesen dass die Notärztin
gesagt hat sie hätte diesen Wagen auch
überhaupt gar nicht benutzt ist wenn er
da gewesen wäre und das scheint auch
ziemlich gesagt sind das hat ein Arzt
der sinnigerweise im Urlaub war als
Ferndiagnose geschrieben worauf sich
dann Zeitungsberichte sozusagen und sie
zu entlasten bezogen haben inzwischen
gibt es ja auch die Feuerwehr weil ich
habe noch eine Frage ja bitte ja also er
hat er hat ihre Worte wiedergegeben ne
und dann und das ist so ein bisschen der
Punkt das kommt dieser jetzt kommt der
der Beitrag der Feuerwehr und
gleichermaßen hat sich schon ein Mensch
gemeldet das wurde auch in der
Süddeutschen Zeitung abgedruckt der
selbst bei der Feuerwehr aktiv ist
anonym bleiben möchte und dort eben
gesagt hat dass ganz aktiv jetzt darauf
geachtet wird welchen Zusammenhang
welche Zusammenhang her gestellt werden
kann und dort ein klares Feindbild
klimaaktivist aufgebaut wird und dieses
Feindbild ist wohl auch vor Ort dort
gewesen gut also Feindbild ist so eine
Sache könnt ihr auch sagen man hat
natürlich viele Gegner sie haben viele
Gegner aber wenn sie natürlich diesen
Gegnern auch noch die Munition liefern
auf die dann mit der dann auf sie
geballert wird ist das eine andere Frage
meine Frage war ja auch dahin denken sie
über diesen Protest
in dieser Form nach denn in jedem Stau
der demnächst durch ihre Verantwortung
entsteht könnte ja ein Rettungswagen
stehen 17 waren das seit dem Sommer nach
Aussage des Senats 13 davon sind
definitiv zu spät zum Einsatz gekommen
war durch diesen von ihnen angezettelten
Stau für das zu einer Reflexion ob das
der richtige Protest ist ja wir sind
durch wir sind durchweg dabei unsere
unsere Protestformen auszuwerten zu
überlegen welche welche anderen Wege für
vielleicht gehen könnten ich möchte aber
auch sich gerne noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass der Grund ja die Ursache
warum dieser Unfall überhaupt passiert
ist dass es nichts mit uns zu tun hat da
und die Ursache ist einfach eine
verfehlte Verkehrspolitik der aktuellen
Regierung und der Regierungen davor da
stellen sich auch diverse Verbände die
sich für eine Verkehrswende einsetzen
auf unsere Seite und sagen
Entschuldigung jeden Tag stirbt im
Verkehr ein Mensch seitdem diese
Diskussionen besteht sind wieder
Menschen gestorben und das wird nicht
entsprechend instrumentalisiert und dann
gerade der Vorwurf aus der Politik an
uns dass wir mit Menschenleben spielen
würden er stößt mir dadurch muss ich
sagen sehr negativ auf weil wir die
Lösungen kennen wie wir wie wir sichere
Radwege und ähnliches
mit der Ursache des Unfalls nichts zu
tun für euch wieder ich glaube man muss
trotzdem man muss trotzdem sagen dass
dass der Stau eben durch diese Proteste
verursacht worden ist das ist ein
kausaler Zusammenhang das das wissen wir
so und wir haben die Regelung dass eben
bestimmte Proteste Formen nicht gehen
und die öffentliche Sicherheit und
Ordnung nicht gefährdet werden darf ja
zurecht gerade damit bestimmte Gefahren
Zusammenhänge sich nicht konkretisieren
die vielleicht am Anfang noch abstrakt
erscheinen und das wird hier durchaus
bewusst gebrochen von daher ist es es
ist wichtig fürs Klima zu protestieren
es ist aber auch wichtig dieses
friedlich zu machen und ich glaube dass
diese Protestformen gerade auch im
Anbetracht der Sache ein ganz ganz
großen Schaden anrichten und ich muss
wirklich sagen leider anrichten weil wir
doch in den letzten Monaten und Jahren
Umdenken in der Bevölkerung bekommen
haben weil wir in der Ampel jetzt auch
viel durchsetzen und umsetzen konnten
weil wir von viel mehr Menschen als eben
vier Jahre zuvor gewählt worden sind um
eine bessere Klimapolitik zu machen von
daher ist es wichtig glaube ich zurück
einfach zum demokratischen Diskurs
demokratischen Meinungsbildung zu
friedlichen Protesten die man sicherlich
immer aus der Zivilgesellschaft braucht
was viele junge Leute von uns verlangen
sie haben ihre Neffen angesprochen ich
habe auch drei Neffen die mit viel
Freude bei Fridays for future mitlaufen
und ich finde es toll was sie machen und
manchmal diskutieren wir ein bisschen
darüber ob wir dergleichen Meinung sind
manchmal sind wir es nicht manchmal sind
wir schon wir lernen sicherlich alle
voneinander aber das muss doch im
rechtsstaatlichen friedlichen Rahmen
passieren und eben nicht durchbrechen
diese Regeln ja bei dem Unfall und dem
tragischen Ausgang für die arme Frau
sind wir genau am Kern des Problems
vielleicht wird nie geklärt ob eine
Ursächlichkeit oder mit Ursächlichkeit
der letzten Generation vorhanden muss
man sagen ist ja die Staatsanwaltschaft
aber noch mal ich will mich auch heute
hier nicht erheben und sagen ja diese
Protestaktion hat dazu geführt und ist
zumindest mit ursächlich am Tod dieser
Frau
aber sie können umgekehrt auch nicht das
Gegenteil behaupten sie können gerade
auch nicht behaupten dass es
auszuschließen ist dass es hier eine mit
Ursächlichkeit an diesem Todesfall
gegeben hat und das können Sie auch in
Zukunft für zukünftige Demonstrationen
zukünftige Staus zukünftige Behinderung
von Rettungskräften und Rettungsdiensten
eben nicht behaupten und nicht
einschätzt und genau das ist das Problem
ihrer Protestaktionen dass Sie sich über
das Gesetz erheben und dass sie damit
auch Leib und Leben anderer Menschen
gefährden oder das zumindest billigend
in Kauf nehmen und das darf ein
Rechtsstaat nicht dulden und deswegen
die dringende Bitte und Aufforderung an
Sie zu protestieren auch gerne mit
witzigen Ideen so dass Aufmerksamkeit
generiert wird aber bitte so dass
Menschen zukünftig nicht mehr gefährdet
werden was war ja welche Psychologie
liegt solchen Protesten eigentlich
zugrunde diese Konflikte tauen ja
tauchen ja häufig auf gerade wenn es bei
um Blockaden geht gibt es ja ein anderer
Form es gibt ja auch die
Kartoffelbrei Würfel auf die
Kunstobjekte welche ist das auch eine
Frage der
Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie wird das gezielt
gemacht kennt man da kann man da die
Grenzen einschätzen vielleicht noch mal
kurz zu sagen dass die Protestformen die
jetzt hier praktiziert werden weder neu
sind noch sonderlich innovativ sind no
offens aber es ist jetzt kein
großartiger also gerade Straßenblockaden
ist ein sehr etabliertes
protestrepertoire was ganz häufig
stattfindet und vor allem auch
historisch und in der Vergangenheit
stattgefunden hat und ganz in den
allermeisten Fällen nicht diesen großen
thematischen Ausbruch auslöst so wie
viele andere Formen der direkten
Aktionen oder des zivilen Ungehorsams
denen sich alle Bewegungen bedienen und
auch in der Vergangenheit schauen wir
zurück immer wieder wichtig waren um
auch Gesetzesreformen in
voranzubringen ja also auch da Streik
unterstreikrecht war nicht von Anfang an
gegeben sondern wurde zerstritten und
damals in dem damaligen
rechtsbezugssystem mit quasi illegalen
Praktiken so und jetzt in dem Fall
wundert es mich dass die diese diese
Praktiken unabhängig jetzt von dem dem
speziellen Fall dieses Unfalls aber
generell dass diese protesttaktiken
gerade bei diesen Gruppen jetzt so
massiv in den Vordergrund rücken im
Vergleich zu anderen Aktionen oder auch
anderen Aktionen die ebenfalls zu
Straßensperren Blockaden oder oder Staus
führen ich würde sagen einhaken mir wird
vorgeworfen wir sollen uns im Rahmen des
Rechtsstaates bewegen und ich sehe das
prinzipiell auch ein aber ich würde also
was verzaja gesagt hat würde ich gerne
weiter ausführen zu Zeiten der such
vergessenbewegung war das ganz klar dass
Frauen nicht wählen dürfen und es wurde
demokratisch von den Männern damals
entschieden das heißt ziviler Widerstand
das was wir tun das ist ein
grundlegender eine grundlegende Methodik
von Menschen schon immer gewesen die
Dinge erkämpft haben die wir heute für
selbstverständlich halten und das haben
Menschen immer gemacht in Zeiten
moralischer Konflikte unter genau da
sind wir jetzt auch wir uns wird
vorgeworfen dass wir das Recht brechen
und das tun wir natürlich auch aber wir
tun das um eben auf den viel größeres
Unrecht hinzuweisen wir haben das
schwarz auf weiß von unserem eigenen
expert in den Rat wir haben es schwarz
auf weiß von der UN es wird zu wenig für
das Klima getan es wird unsere Ziele ein
Widerspruch also sowohl Test haben ist
kein Widerspruch ich kenne jedenfalls
kein und auch das hier auf etwas ganz
Wichtiges hinweisen das ist also
zunächst möchte ich möchte sagen dass es
dass uns gerade vorgeworfen würde
undemokratisch zu sein und das wollte
ich einfach sagen dass es nicht stimmt
das ist der eine Punkt und der andere
Punkt ist eben wir haben ja genau jetzt
die Möglichkeit wieder darüber zu
diskutieren was gerade passiert es läuft
gerade die conference of the Partys kurz
vorher wurde uns gesagt wie gesagt
schwarz auf weiß wir verpassen unsere
Ziele und wir verwirr wie sie einhalten
würden es ist nicht genug und es wird
mittlerweile wird es von allen gesagt
wir verpassen unsere Ziele als sein das
Fußballergebnisse sein als als würde
Hertha BSC nicht aufsteigen oder sowas
und aber warum ist hier geht und da
diesen Rahmen möchte ich bitte gerne
setzen worum es hier geht ist jetzt ist
die Zukunft unserer Zivilisation in der
Sendung auch noch besprechen es geht im
Moment jetzt noch um die Frage des
Protestes für euch wieder wenn ich es
gerade richtig verstanden habe gesagt es
gibt also wieder Ungehorsam ist erlaubt
in einem gewissen Rahmen wo ist er
eigentlich strafbar oder wo
überschreitet er die strafrechtlichen
Grenzen wenn wir zum Beispiel den
Tatbestand der Nötigung nehmen haben wir
die zweite Reihe Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes dass wir dass
wir dort eben wo aktiv durch
physische Gewalt andere daran gehindert
werden weiterzukommen das ist die Grenze
eben entsprechend überschritten wird und
das ist hier in den meisten Fällen wir
diskutieren jetzt ja kein konkreten Fall
aber in den meisten Fällen einschlägig
und eben wie gesagt auch
höchstrichterlich durchaus schon
entschieden ähnlich wie bei den
Kunstwerken die Frage der
Sachbeschädigung auch sehr sehr
naheliegt im konkreten Fall muss das
dann immer noch mal geprüft werden eben
durch eine erkennenden Richter mit den
Regelungen die wir haben und den
Strafrahmen von denen ich sage dass sie
sehr gut sind und die Politik da nicht
quasi von unten es hochschreiben muss
weil es gerade populär ist zu sagen die
Strafen die schon gefällt worden sind
seien nicht hoch genug ohne dass jemand
darüber nachgedacht hat wer
möglicherweise dort Angeklagter war wie
die Einkommensverhältnisse waren etc was
ja bei Geldstrafen immer
einen Faktor ist ob es schon eintragen
im Bundeszentralregister gab etc das
sind Dinge die kann dann nur die Justiz
entsprechend beurteilen und das muss sie
auch aber am Beispiel jetzt der Nötigung
der Sachbeschädigung habe ich habe ich
versucht das zu erklären und da sind
einfach Grenzen überschritten und der
Unterschied jetzt zum Beispiel zum
Frauenwahlrecht ist ja schon zumindest
aus meiner Sicht dass es eben gerade im
Bundestag und auch auf in vielen anderen
Gremien und Foren Vereinten Nationen etc
17 Nachhaltigkeitsziele
ein ganz großes Bewusstsein dafür gibt
dass wir was machen müssen dass wir
schneller werden müssen dass die
entsprechenden Studien und Erkenntnisse
und so weiter ja teilweise auch von der
Politik in Auftrag gegeben worden sind
um zu gucken wie können wir am besten
Handeln woran müssen wir drehen an
welchen Gesetzen aber da sind wir dran
da ist es gut Anschub zu kriegen und
schneller zu werden möglicherweise das
wollen auch viele auch junge Abgeordnete
gerade im ich habe ja gesagt die
Zusammensetzung hat sich aus einem Grund
geändert aber ich glaube dass wir eher
dafür werben müssen dass wir noch mehr
Zustimmung der Bevölkerung kriegen und
da sind glaube ich diese Proteste
kontraproduktiv also wir werden genau
diesen Aspekt noch was ist da sinnvoll
wie muss man es machen und es geht ja
darum das Ziel Klima zu schützen und die
Welt CO2
CO2-frei zu machen darum noch eine Frage
jetzt abschließend zu dieser
strafrechtlichen Frage wenn man jetzt
Strafverschärfungen so wie es ihre
Fraktion da möchte
ins Gesetz gießt ist ja nicht die Gefahr
groß dass der Protest kriminalisiert
wird ich meine immerhin gibt es ja aus
ihrer Fraktion vom stellvertretenden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der Hinweis wir
müssen eine Klima RAF verhindern ich
glaube das hat auch in der Union
Fraktion nicht nur zu eitelfreudige für
diese Bemerkung ist das nicht die Gefahr
dass man die da gleich wieder in eine
Ecke stellt das ist ja aber genau die
Befürchtung und die man haben muss es
findet eine Radikalisierung statt und
zwar sehr sehr schnell und deswegen
wissen wir auch als Rechtsstaaten jetzt
schon statt ja eine Radikalisierung von
friedlichen in der Tat friedlichen
Protesten etwa von Fridays for future
und anderen Gruppierungen jetzt hin zu
Rechtsbrüchen und die werden ja auch
eingestanden es ist aber keine
friedliche Protestaktion weil es wird
Gewalt ausgeübt so wie es die Kollegin
beschrieben hat auf die Autofahrer die
da quasi als unschuldige Bürger mit in
Geiselhaft genommen werden für ihre
politischen Zielsetzungen da kann es
nicht darum gehen um welche politischen
Zielsetzungen es geht und jetzt zum
Thema Strafrahmen wir haben ja das
Phänomen dass jedenfalls
der bisherige geltende Strafrahmen
offensichtlich keine Wirkung auf diese
radikalisierten Proteste zeigt
Geldstrafen werden offensichtlich in
Kauf genommen eingepreist und deswegen
ist es schon so dass wir als Staat auch
eine gewisse lenkungs- und
erziehungswirkung des Strafrechts
erzielen müssen und deswegen wissen wir
Freiheitsstrafen mehr in den Vordergrund
stellen das ist letztlich zum Thema
nicht verurteilt werden
normalerweise niemanden
mit Freiheit
in Zukunft ich wollte diesen Aspekt nur
vielleicht dass wir noch auf einen
anderen
schon ganz kurz zwei Punkte erstens sie
haben es angesprochen nach § 47 StGB
soll bei unter 6 Monaten oder keine
Freiheitsstrafe verhängt werden nur in
ganz außerordentlichen Fällen ist das
der Fall das kann kein Regelbeispiel
sein das muss sich in der Tat selbst
begründen von daher würde das überhaupt
keine Wirkung erzeugen hier diese diese
Sache und zweitens ist schon ganz ganz
lange auch wissenschaftliche anerkannt
dass Strafen und härtere Strafen keine
abschreckende Wirkung haben das sieht
man auch daran dass in Ländern wo es
viel schärfere Strafen gibt nicht
weniger Straftaten begangen werden das
sieht man im übrigen auch in Deutschland
wo in Bayern die Strafen häufig sehr
viel strenger ausfallen als aber nicht
weniger Kriminalität gibt als zum
Beispiel in
Bremen oder Niedersachsen diesen
rechtspolitischen Diskurs an der Stelle
beenden wir damit wir zu der letzten
Generation zurückkehren kennen die diese
Organisation letzte Generation
wer ist das eigentlich wer steckt da
dahinter was sind jetzt in aller Munde
man kannte vorher eigentlich nur Fridays
for future und extinction Rebellion
jetzt kommt eine neue die ja
international tätig ist und auch
koordiniert wird können Sie da uns kurz
noch was dazu sagen da müssen sie meinen
Kollegen jetzt hier unter dem Ermitteln
von außen betrachten
also es ist jetzt nicht so dass wir
irgendwie geheime Daten über diese
Organisationen und so weiter sammeln das
dementsprechend kann ich Ihnen auch nur
das sehen was ich von außen wahrnehme
und in der in den Diskurses und in der
Debatte ist ich wollte hier nur noch
anmerken dass eben ja der genau der
Punkt ist also was mich so wundert an
dieser Debatte ist immer dass dass ich
sehr schnell auf diese Handlung auf
diesen rechts des Kurs bezieht was total
legitimes und gerade aus dem politischen
Bereich ist das völlig legitim aber eben
genau dieser Konflikt zu den
Gerechtigkeitsvorstellungen sie haben es
ja gerade angesprochen wir müssen
handeln aber wie und warum ist dann
immer nur die letzte Generation sich
rechtfertigen für ihr Handeln sondern
das geht ja auch um wir müssen handeln
und wir alle müssen uns eigentlich
fragen was bedeutet das für uns und was
sind denn unsere Vorstellungen davon und
warum gehen denn da die Sachen nicht
weiter
intensiv damit beschäftigen in meine
Frage ging auch dahin ob die Stärke dann
formuliere ich jetzt anders die Stärke
der letzten Generation ist dies auch in
anderen Ländern gibt dass sie
international gut vernetzt und gut
koordiniert ist das kann man das so
sagen
also im Vergleich zu der generellen
Vernetzung von sozialen Bewegungen
weltweit ist es jetzt hier kein großes
Aushängeschild oder auch ich würde also
tut mir leid wieder in der Offense
nichts Besonderes so also auch nicht
sonderlich
stärker oder weniger stark wie ich das
sonst bei anderen Sachen nachnehmen
machen also im Gegenteil ihr noch recht
klein muss man sagen so also im
Vergleich zu jetzt auch extinction
Rebellion oder anderen auch anderen
Gruppen aus der Klimabewegung die doch
auch sehr breiter oder sichtbarer
vernetzt sind sie koordinieren sich ja
wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe
sozusagen im Rahmen dieses climate
emergency found also in der Stiftung aus
Kalifornien die verschiedene zivile
Proteste für Klimaschutz und gegen gegen
die Gefahren des Klimas
inszeniert haben sie machen gemeinsames
Motto wir sind die letzte Generation wir
tun was auch immer nötig ist
ist das diese diese internationale die
Internationalität ist doch etwas für
sich dagegenseitig antreiben wie
koordinieren sie das auf internationale
Ebene in der Tat ist Klima ja nicht auf
ein Land beschränkt das ist der richtig
genau
also ja wir sind vernetzt aber jede
Bewegung steht schon auch für sich
selbst jede Bewegung steht für sich
selbst weil die Menschen vor Ort
natürlich eher
auch eher ein Gefühl haben was gerade
interessante Themen eben sein können die
wir in den Vordergrund stellen können
genau also insofern ja wir sind vernetzt
aber wir sind auch durchaus weiter
eigenständig irgendwas übrigens auch
eine Menge Spenden das ist nicht so dass
wir nur über diesen Pfand gehen gerade
jetzt innerhalb der letzten Woche sind
sehr sehr viele sprechen
zum Teil mit prominenten Geldgebern
dieser Franzi haben aber auch Spenden
hier im Inland das ist
ja auch schon einiges zusammengekommen
sechsstelliger Betrag habe ich gelesen
persönlich keiner übersehen vielleicht
haben Sie eine Übersicht über die Art
wie sie wie Proteste organisiert werden
das habe ich einen großen Interesse
gelesen sie haben bilden für eine
Gruppierung die jetzt Proteste macht
durchführt in Museen auf der Straße
sogenannte Bezugsgruppen die Arbeiten
solange diese Proteste laufen diese
Blockaden und diese Kartoffelbrei Würfel
quasi zusammen in einer WG leben die da
gibt es die Bienen das sind diejenigen
die die Proteste durchführen und einen
Gärtner oder eine Gärtnerin diese Bienen
solange versorgt damit sich nicht wieder
so Wäsche waschen kümmern noch um
Nahrungsmittel und die Gärtner bemühen
sich auch um die die verhaftet worden
sind klickt eigentlich ziemlich straff
organisiert also das heißt das ist eine
auch eine Stärke von ihnen eine Machart
das in dieser Weise nicht einfach dem
Zufalls überlassen morgen sehen wir uns
bei der S-Bahn-Station so und so und
dann schauen wir mal wo wir uns
hinsetzen sondern das ist ja fast
militärisch geplant
da legen wir jetzt aber Wort in den Mund
das ist das ist das ist das ist geplant
natürlich es geht wie gesagt es geht
nicht darum eine lockere Demo zu
organisieren es ist nicht wir treffen
uns dann da und wählen mit bunten Fahnen
das haben wir lange genug gemacht das
machen wir immer noch und mit dem Effekt
das Politiker erinnern sich daneben
stellen und sagen vielen Dank wir haben
es jetzt verstanden und dann immer noch
ein Klimapaket haben was er fein
verfassungsfeindlich ist und das
passiert einfach und wir nach wie vor
sehen es passiert nicht genug
das ist korrekt wir sind in Gruppen
gekommen Gruppen zusammen und das hat
auch ganz einfach den Beweggrund dass
wir das ist eine unfassbar emotional
anstrengende Sache ist generell eine
sehr stressige Sache keiner kein Mensch
der bei uns dabei ist macht das zum Spaß
ich sitze da von Menschen die mich
anschreien ich werde von Polizisten in
Handschellen gesetzt ich werde
eingesperrt in Einzelhaft in Frankfurt
war ich fünf Tage lang in Einzelhaft mit
einer halben teilweise in der ganzen
Stunde Ausgang am Tag ich bin ganz
normaler Mensch wie jeder andere auch
ich habe kein Interesse daran all das zu
tun und dementsprechend ist es eben auch
wichtig dass wir für uns selbst eine
Kultur finden in der wir füreinander da
sein können und in der wir uns auffangen
können auch wenn wir Gewalt erfahren was
gerade durch die Berichterstattung diese
übertriebene Berichterstattung der
letzten Woche
extremer geworden ist und das sind eben
genauso eine Möglichkeiten um und diesen
Stress um um die Emotionen die aufkommen
abzufangen eine Frage noch Fridays for
future das ist ja die weitaus bekanntere
Organisation ist das eigentlich eine
komplementärorganisation sie verteilen
sich die eingehen zur Demo die anderen
mit dem Kleber auf die Straße oder so
eine konkurrenzorganisation also sie
finden mich auch nach wie vor auf
Fridays for future Demonstration das ist
ganz wichtig ich glaube auch dass es für
das ist generell wichtig ist es ist die
Klimawissenschaften sagen uns wir haben
jetzt einen verschwindend geringen
Zeitraum ungefähr zwei Jahre in denen
wir den grundlegenden Wandel eingeleitet
haben müssen die UN sagt wir brauchen
einen grundlegenden Umbau unseres
Wirtschaftssystems und unseres
gesellschaftlichen Systems die Frage ist
wie kommen wir dahin und dementsprechend
ist eben wichtig dass alle Menschen sich
jetzt genau in diesem Moment diese Frage
stellen was ist mein Anteil am Wandel
was ist mein Anteil daran dass ich jetzt
machen kann um diesen Wandel
herbeizuführen und dementsprechend habe
ich natürlich ich würde das super gerne
begrüßen wenn wir 20 Millionen bei
Fridays for future Demonstrationen sind
einzig wir sind an diesem Punkt dass wir
riesendemonstrationen hatten die von der
Politik teilweise beklatscht worden sind
und immer noch nicht da wo wir sein
müssten und da setzt unser pro jetzt
eben an damit wir an diesem Thema nicht
mehr vorbeikommen dass wir dieses Thema
nicht mehr ignorieren können wir haben
noch zwei Jahre und dann haben wir kaum
noch eine Chance dass wieder einzufangen
und die Konsequenz heißt der Kollaps der
Zivilisation und die anderen
Möglichkeiten die wir haben ist eben
eine neue Gesellschaft zu bauen in der
wir gemeinsam an Lösungen arbeiten
wenn sie andere
Potenz also ich meine ich meine es
wirklich ernst und ich versuche es auch
insofern gut zu meinen weil durch durch
das
Festkleben auf der Straße oder eben die
Kartoffelbrei Aktionen etc werden doch
mehr Menschen vor den Kopf gestoßen und
verstehen eben nicht in welche Richtung
diese Proteste gerade gehen beschäftigen
sich mehr mit der Form des Protestes als
mit der Sache an sich von der sie ja
sagen dass sie eben für diese Sachen
mehr Leute gewinnen wollen und ich
glaube wirklich dass Fridays for future
sehr sehr viel geschafft hat dass
die Proteste da eben erfolgreich waren
dass im Bundestag viele Leute sitzen die
ja auch bei Fridays for future
mitgelaufen sind oder sich da engagiert
haben etc und da jetzt versuchen eben
Politik zu machen und so zu überzeugen
also man muss ja Netzwerke bilden etc
und nicht eben die
es ist immer so schwierig und etwas
plakativ Beispiele zu finden aber
trotzdem die Krankenschwester die im
Stau steht und nicht nicht zur Arbeit
kommt um Leuten zu helfen die wird
hinterher kein größeres Verständnis für
Klima und klimaproteste haben
als vorher nur einwerfe weil wir reden
jetzt darüber welchen Sinn ja diese
Proteste machen wo sich hinführen 86
Prozent eine Umfrage diese Woche
herausgekommen sind der Meinung dass die
letzte Generation mit diesen
Protestaktionen dem Klimaschutz schadet
also die sind jetzt gegen ihre
Organisation sondern sie schaden ihr 86%
ist eine ganze Menge das heißt die Frage
ob da Weg und Ziel noch zusammen passen
muss man ja auch stellen aber vielleicht
ja das ist ganz sicherlich so dass sie
dem Schaden und wenn wir guten und
schnellen Klimaschutz wollen dann wissen
wir die Menschen mitnehmen wir müssen
sie gewinnen für dieses Projekt für
diese menschheitsaufgabe da bin ich auch
ganz bei Ihnen das machen sie da
erreichen sie momentan exakt das
Gegenteil dessen und weil Sie
angesprochen haben wie die Vernetzung
der letzten Generation ist also wir
haben Solidaritätskundgebungen von der
interventionistischen linke sie
empfehlen auf ihrer Homepage dass wenn
man einen Strafprozess hat dass man dann
bei der Rote Hilfe anklopfen kann die
dann die Prozesskosten übernehmen kann
das sind beides linksextremistische
Organisationen die vom Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet werden insofern ist die
Vernetzung nicht nur mit irgendeinem
Pfand in in Amerika gegeben oder wie sie
selbst sagen mit Fridays for Futures
sondern eben auch mit anderen
Gruppierungen die sich da auch bei ihnen
einmischen untermischen wie auch immer
und das ist genau die Gefahr der
Radikalisierung die wir bei ihnen sehen
kann das sein Frau seyak das
Protestbewegung egal jetzt welche es
gibt ja viele
immer Gefahr laufen quasi gekapert zu
werden von politischen Organisationen
meistens auch von extremistischen ist es
ein generelles Phänomen
gekapert also soziale Bewegungen sind
Netzwerke sie reden auch immer von
Organisationen das sind gar keine
Organisationen als solche sondern
soziale Bewegungen sind lose
Zusammenschlüsse von Individuen zum Teil
auch Organisationen und das ist nicht so
sie ich habe nicht so dass jemand da als
Master meinte oben sagt und uns steuert
und sagt so vernetzen wir uns aus wie
ein strategischen Schlachtplan dahinter
sondern das entwickelt sich generisch
und es entstehen Verbindungen manche
sind digital manche sind physisch also
es ist jetzt nicht so dass da dass es da
eine straffe Hierarchisierung und
Organisierung gibt das zählt vielleicht
für einzelne Gruppen wenn man dann
schaut wie man sich organisiert im
kleinen und das andere sind sind
breitere Vernetzungen und das heißt aber
nicht dass Bewegungen an sich sind nicht
steuerbar von diesen einzelnen
Knotenpunkten deswegen bleiben wir
einfach mal bei Fridays for future sieht
man auch immer wieder diese
selbstreflektionsprozesse sich von
Leuten zu befreien die von außen
zugeschrieben werden als
Führungspersönlichkeiten und so weiter
also man versucht das ja auch immer
wieder zu unterlaufen im oben auch immer
wieder solche
kooptierungsversuche und so weiter von
außen die häufig auch zum Beispiel von
Parteien kommen und so weiter wieder
abzublocken so und das ist auch ein eine
Bewegung ist ein diskursraum in dem
Aushandlungen stattfindet und Bewegungen
nehmen auch solche Themen nicht leicht
es ist nicht die Bewegung die die Taktik
rechtfertigt ja und und deswegen gibt es
ja auch diese Unterscheidungen selbst in
der Gruppe ja wo man sagt was sind die
Grenzen für mein eigenes Handeln weil
die Leute selbst reflektieren das ja
auch immer für sich wie weit will ich
gehen was bedeutet für mich Rechtsbruch
was bedeutet für mich Gewalt gegen mich
gegen andere und so weiter also das ist
ein das ist ein Prozess den jeder
aushandeln muss und auch bei zivilen
Ungehorsam insgesamt ist es wirklich so
es bezieht sich der Rechtsbruch in der
Regel auf einen spezifischen Aspekt in
der Gesellschaft aber man erkennt das
System an und man kennt auch die
Rechtmäßigkeit des Rechtssystem an unter
anderem indem man keinen Widerstand
gegen Verhaftungen zeigt oder eben auch
akzeptiert das strafrechtsverfahren so
man sagt ja nicht strafrechtliche
Verfolgung weiß ich nicht ob das jemand
tun würde bei Ihnen oder nicht aber
quasi im letztendlichen ist das Prinzip
nicht zu sagen das ganze Rechtssystem
ist schlecht sondern wir brauchen nur
ein einzelnen Punkt und da wollen wir
ansetzen und das wollen wir ist der
Rechtsbruch der Weg auf illegitime
Handlungen zu verweisen und das muss
niemand so schlucken das ist ja genau
der Punkt das muss diskutiert werden und
es ist wichtig dass jeder der
unterschiedliche Positionen hat das darf
niemand schlucken wenn er es mit dem
Recht wenn er ist mit dem Rechtsstaat
ernst nimmt darf man dieses nicht
hinnehmen wenn sie sagen oder Ihre
Organisation sagt wir tun alles was
notwendig ist alles was notwendig ist
aus ihrer Sicht würde ja auch bedeuten
mehr zu tun als wir bisher haben erleben
müssen und deswegen muss man das schon
ganz genau hinschauen und darf da auch
nicht sagen naja bei dem einen Thema da
können wir mal ein Auge zudrücken oder
ähnliches weil dann kommt das nächste
Thema wo fangen wir an und wo hören wir
auf es darf einfach in unserer
demokratischen Gesellschaft nicht sein
dass ich eine in der Gruppe eine
Minderheit über die Mehrheit erhebt und
deswegen auch das wurde gerade vorhin
angesprochen ist das Verhalten
die Denkweise von ihnen und demokratisch
ja fast schon antidemokratisch nochmal
zu dem zu dem Ziel dass die letzte
Generation sich gesetzt hat das ist das
Ziel ist eine Welt in der alle Menschen
Menschen wirklich leben können indem sie
genügend zu essen haben Dach überm Kopf
in einer sauberen Umwelt leben darauf
haben auch alle Menschen ein Recht und
viele haben es heute möglicherweise
sogar die Mehrheit nicht kein Recht das
heißt Sie hätten eins aber es wird nicht
verwirklicht wenn sie jetzt gleichzeitig
sehen dass dieser Protest möglicherweise
kontraproduktiv ist also selbst ihre
wohlmeinenden Sympathisanten vergrault
mit dem Protestformen wäre es dann
Überlegung jetzt zu sagen dann muss
einfach der viel beschwerlichere weg
gegangen werden nämlich die vielen die
zwar sagen Klimaschutz ist wichtig aber
mein persönliches Verhalten ändere ich
nicht das ist ja der Klassiker in
unserer Gesellschaft ohne jemanden was
zu unterstellen dass und da viel mehr
noch Überzeugungsarbeit leisten muss mit
wissenschaftlicher Expertise mit
persönlicher Erfahrung auch mit
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit den Leuten klar zu
machen dass so wie wir jetzt leben dass
das nicht mehr funktioniert ob sie jetzt
die letzte nicht Vorgesetzte Generation
ist bleibt dahingestellt aber dass das
nicht mehr weitergeht dass das
klimakollabiert aber dass sie eine
Methode verwenden die dieses Ziel
eigentlich letztendlich verfehlt müssen
sie da nicht auch Umdenken was die Form
angeht vielen Dank für die Frage auf
jeden Fall
also das passiert ja ich bin 31 Jahre
alt und dieses informieren und
einfordern und debattieren das passiert
länger als ich lebe und seitdem sind
auch die Konsequenzen klar die uns
erwarten
wir sind jetzt an dem Punkt angelangt wo
wir wo wir einen grundlegenden Wandel
brauchen wir hätten das vor 5 40 50
Jahren hätten wir das noch anders
gestalten können das ist jetzt anders
der Punkt ist wie kriegen wie schaffen
wir das wie erreichen wir einen
grundlegenden Wandel denn ich glaube
weil sie auch sagt weil sie mir eine
vorwerfen oder viele von mir vorwerfen
dass ich dass wir Menschen vergrauen ich
glaube dass eine vorherrschende Meinung
gerade ist dass ich als Mensch sowieso
nichts verändern kann ich kann irgendwie
alle vier Jahre gehe ich zur Wahl und
setzt mein Kreuz und weiß ich weiß beim
wählen was da was da allein schon im
Parteiprogramm steht reicht nicht aus
weil ich kann mich belesen und ich sehe
das wird nicht ausreichen dann gehe ich
auf Demonstrationen und das passiert
immer noch nicht genug denn ja es ist
viel passiert ja das Bewusstsein ist
stärker da und es sind und es werden
auch gerade aktuell wieder Maßnahmen
getroffen das Besondere beim Klima ist
aber wenn wir diese Klima Kipppunkte
überschreiten dass wir das nicht
zurückdrehen können das heißt es ist
egal ob es das zweitgrößte oder das
größte Paket ist
ausreichend groß sein und da sind wir
meilenweit von Weg das sagt das sagt
sie brauchen die Unterstützung der
Gesellschaft vielen Dank genau und da
sind wir uns ja sogar alle einig dass
wir dafür die Unterstützung der Menschen
brauchen die kommt wieder dahin und dann
müssen wir anfangen wirklich offen
darüber zu reden dann können wir nicht
mehr sagen im Wahlkampf wir halten die
1,5 Grad mit diesem oder mit jedem Ziel
sondern wir müssen jetzt hingehen und
auch als Bundesregierung wirklich
eingestehen und da haben sie auch heute
hier wieder die Möglichkeit zu sagen wir
haben unsere Klimaziele verfehlt wir tun
zu wenig und dann müssen wir darüber
neue Wege führen das sind damit müssen
wir den Anfang diesen den Diskurs
innerhalb innerhalb der Bevölkerung
anzustoßen aber dass wir mehr machen
müssen haben es heute unter anderem der
Debatte und den ganz vielen weiteren
Debatten herausgestellt worden ist ich
habe gar kein Problem das hier zu sagen
wir müssen definitiv mehr machen wir
müssen mehr machen um um die
Nachhaltigkeitsziele insbesondere zu
erreichen das sind alles Punkte die Sie
angesprochen haben die sie ja auch
fordern dass wenn man wenn man nicht nur
die Menschen mit man nicht nur
Deutschland sondern weltweit guckt weil
das muss man ja gerade bei Klimafragen
ein Punkt aber auch noch sie sagen dass
viele Leute das Gefühl haben dass man
als einzelner Mensch nichts bewegen kann
ich muss trotzdem weil sich der
innerlich bei mir ganz ganz viel auf
sträubt ich bin als junger Mensch in der
Partei eingetreten um etwas zu bewegen
und ich habe als relativ junger Mensch
und auch für den Bundestag kandidiert
das heißt jeder kann etwas machen in dem
eben mitmacht indem er sich politisch
einmal indem er sich
zivilgesellschaftlich einbringt etc und
ich ich glaube wirklich an die Kraft von
einzelnen Menschen etwas zu bewegen von
daher keiner soll oder darf sich
ohnmächtig fühlen und jeder ist
eingeladen mitzumachen wer zusammen sind
wir definitiv am stärksten und wir haben
ja viel zu tun wir sprechen jetzt
natürlich hauptsächlich über die
Proteste und so weiter aber uns wäre es
hoffentlich ein zumindest mir sehr viel
lieber wenn wir Dreiviertelstunde
tatsächlich über das Klima sprechen
würden uns fragen wie können wir das
denn ändern wie können wir denn
vorangehen wie können wir das
deutschlandweit wie können wir das
weltweit machen wie können wir die
erneuerbaren Energien besser und
schneller etc ausbauen da hat die
Bundesregierung viel beschlossen ich bin
froh der Teil gewesen zu sein es gibt
einige Länder muss muss ich leider muss
ich leider sagen auch in dieser Runde
ich verstehe nicht warum es in Bayern
noch eine 10h-regelung gibt das finde
ich einfach vollkommen falsch in der
Klimakrise in der wir uns bewegen das
sind Punkte über die wir politisch
diskutieren müssen wo wir ganz ganz viel
machen können und es ist doch schade
dass wir jetzt eben über die Art des
Protestes diskutieren schaffen sie das
in zwei Jahren schaffen sie das in zwei
Jahren unsere Wirtschaft an unsere
wirtschaftsidee und unsere Gesellschaft
umzubauen das ist meiner Frage
das nicht schaffen werden die Frage ist
aber wenn wir jetzt darüber reden was
ist eigentlich nötig wird zu viel über
die Form des Protest geredet und zu
wenig über den Inhalt nicht der Ziel ist
ja mit der Form diese Aufmerksamkeit zu
generieren um auch über den Inhalt zu
diskutieren und da muss ich sagen also
es hat schon auch eine gewissen Art von
verdrängungsdiskurs und ich kann das
auch verstehen für alle Armen
politiker:innen die in diesen Themenfeld
sich damit beschäftigen denn
Klimapolitik ist wirklich harte Politik
und es sind wirklich große Fragen harte
fahren und wenn man damit konfrontiert
ist wenn man sagen muss oder sich
positionieren muss wenn es jetzt
wirklich schnell gehen soll also quasi
sich ernsthaft mit den Forderungen
auseinandersetzen muss dann gerät man
auch schnell ins Stocken denn das ist
eine große Themen schwere Themen und die
kommen dann sehr schnell zu
ressourcenverteilungsfragen etc da ist
es viel viel leichter sich über die Form
zu unterhalten dasselbe zählt für alle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für alle ist es
leichter sich über diese Form jetzt
aufzuregen und damit auseinanderzusetzen
als zu sagen so was bedeutet das jetzt
ernsthaft für mich ist ja nicht nur die
Politik der Adressat das sind wir alle
der Adressat und was würde das für mich
bedeuten mit meinen Urlaub unterhalten
Konsumverhalten und alles so ja und dass
man das versucht gar nicht also dass man
das nicht an sich heranlässt ist ja auch
ein Schutzmechanismus eines jeden
Einzelnen und ich glaube auch
tatsächlich dass das diese
selbstschutzfunktion oder
verdrängungsfunktion einen Grund dafür
ist dass jetzt gerade so hart gegenüber
protestaktiken die wie gesagt eigentlich
nicht sonderlich neu sind
so sehr darüber diskutiert wird darum
wird einfach ist die der Klimaschutz
einfach viel zu lange das sind ja auch
die Parteien sie waren ja in der letzten
Legislaturperiode sogar noch in einer
gemeinsamen Koalition gewesen einfach
viel zu sehr vernachlässigt worden hat
man das einfach laufen lassen und jetzt
durch Fridays for future macht man auf
ist da nicht auch viel Schuld an der
Politik hängen geblieben dass jetzt
schnell sagen kann hätte ja eigentlich
vor 20 30 Jahren schon passieren müssen
naja es ist auch mal es ist auch einiges
passiert in den letzten Jahren das darf
man nicht einfach so unter den Teppich
erklären aber selbstverständlich das ist
gar keine Frage hätte auch mehr
werden können und müssen und das will
ich auch sagen wir diskutieren jetzt
über die Protestformen aber das führt
nicht dazu dass wir die Debatten und
Diskussionen über Klimaschutz wie wir in
machen können und wollen deshalb
verdrängt wird das wäre schlimm also
diese Wirkung haben sie mit Sicherheit
auch nicht das war ja dann auch eine
eine falsche Wirkung aber das Mitnehmen
der Menschen das wird dadurch viel viel
schwieriger und wenn sie Ultimaten an
die Bundesregierung Stellen geht ja gar
nicht an uns wenn Sie Ultimaten an die
Bundesregierung stellen dann ist es ein
Erpressungsversuch das kann auch eine
Bundesregierung werden also das Ziel zu
erreichen mit einem solchen Ultimatum
wird eher ferner werden weil es die
Bundesregierung gerade wegen dem
Ultimatum nicht nacherschneiden 20
Sekunden nehmen wir ein bisschen nämlich
am Ende der Sendung ganz kurz dass ihr
kurz darauf reagieren aber wirklich nur
ganz kurz alles klar vielen Dank
wir erreichen die ich glaube ich bin
davon überzeugt dass viele Menschen sich
mit dieser Systematik auskennen und
diese Problematik kennen und dass sie
wissen was auf uns zukommt und dass sie
auch wissen dass es schlimm wird und die
Frage ist wie kommen wir ins Handeln das
kommen wir das schaffen wir nur wenn wir
groß in uns vernetzen das bedeutet wie
gesagt alle Menschen haben gerade am
müssen sich jetzt die Frage stellen was
mache ich in den nächsten zwei Jahren
und es muss nicht bei uns sein das kann
auch bei Fraser future sein aber es muss
effektiver Protest sein in die in die
Richtung in die Frage wie bauen wir
unsere Gesellschaft um damit wir das
Überstehen gut dann war das jetzt der
Punkt gewesen noch ein Hinweis das kann
die Gerichtsverhandlung gewesen das sind
Fernsehstudio das wird auch Frau
eichwede bestätigen weil sie immer
gesagt haben sie müssen sich hierzu Wehr
setzen sind politische Diskussionen ich
bedanke mich bei Sonja eichwede bei Theo
Schnarr bei Sabrina sayak und Alexander
drum Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer nächstes Phoenix
geschmacksformat am kommenden Montag 22
Uhr 15 Unter den Linden moderiert von
Michaela Polster
aktuell ist es weiteres in Phoenix der
Tag mit Konstanze abratsky darin geht es
auch um den Bundestag und zwar um die
Verabschiedung des Bürgergeldes bleiben
Sie bei uns